[Musik]
am Ende ist das eingetreten was viele
befürchtet haben
Putin beschließt teilweise Mobilmachung
seine atomdrohungen sind angeblich kein
Bluff die Gesamtzahl der Reservisten die
einberufen werden könnte laut
offiziellen bis zu 300.000 betragen kurz
nach Punkt ins Rede berichteten
russische Medien von einem starken
Anstieg der Nachfrage nach Flugtickets
ins Ausland am 21 September 2022 ordnete
der russische Diktator Wladimir Putin
die teilmobilisierung der Truppen an was
die Einberufung oder den Einsatz
russischer Zivilisten im Kampf bedeutet
theoretisch handelt es sich dabei um
eine Einberufung von Zivilisten die eine
militärische Ausbildung haben und in der
Reserve eingeschrieben waren zumindest
dachten sie das denn die Wahrheit ist
dass ich die Rekrutierung als eine
riesiges Chaos entpuppt hat und alle
möglichen Leute einberufen werden aber
lasst uns putis mobil machen und lieber
am Ende dieses Videos analysieren denn
ihre weitreichenden Folgen werden
wesentlich besser zu verstehen sein
nachdem wird das Haupt dieses Videos
behandelt haben
denn auch wenn es nur so aussieht dass
es nur eine Frage der Zeit war bis diese
Entscheidung fallen würde die
Mobilmachung war Putins ultima ratio
wenn man dann überhaupt noch von ratio
reden kann sie ist ein Zeichen dafür wie
schwach die russische Armee mittlerweile
geworden ist der Einmarsch in die
Ukraine hat sich von einer Sache des
patriotischen stolzes Russlands zum
schlimmsten Albtraum des kremmels
entwickelt nachrichtendienstliche
Versäumnisse Überschätzung der
militärischen Fähigkeiten Korruption in
der Militärindustrie und die Vorstellung
dass ich die Ukraine nach dem einmal der
russischen Truppen wie ein Zuckerwürfel
auflösen würde haben dazu geführt dass
die Dinge für den Kreml und für Russland
nicht schlechter hätten ausgehen können
ich meine was soll ich sagen in
vergangenen Videos haben wir hier
official Politik bereits viele der
Gründe für das russische Bargeld
angeführt die Vorhersagen und
Einschätzungen die wir bereits vor
Monaten mit euch geteilt haben erweisen
sich nun alle als zutreffend besonders
bitter für alle put ganz Defätisten oder
einfach nur Naivlinge jede kann diesen
nachprüfen indem er sich diese Videos
ansieht und mit der heutigen Realität
vergleicht was wir aber noch nicht
richtig behandelt haben ist eine der
Hauptfaktoren der Invasion zu einem
Albtraum für Moskau gemacht hat ein
Grund der von Vladimir Putin selbst
erkannt und angeprangert wurde in diesem
Video geht es um westliche Waffen und
ich kann euch versprechen dass dabei
kein Auge trocken bleiben wird also
schnallt euch an und lasst uns sofort
loslegen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
bei der Geschwindigkeit mit der sich der
Krieg in der Ukraine entwickelt da hat
sich einige von euch vielleicht gar
nicht mehr an diese Bilder erinnern in
den ersten Tagen der verbrecherischen
russischen Invasionen waren nur wenige
Menschen optimistisch was die Zukunft
der Ukraine angeht dabei dachte nicht
nur Putin das Kiew in drei Tagen fallen
würde nein auch viele andere
Spitzenpolitiker viel mit ihrer
besonders krassen und Informiertheit und
mangelnden Urteilsfähigkeit auf der
deutsche Finanzminister Christian
Lindner zum Beispiel ging davon aus dass
die Ukraine innerhalb weniger Stunden
fallen würde bei seinem ersten Treffen
mit dem ukrainischen Botschafter gleich
nach Kriegsausbruch fragte er diesen
doch tatsächlich wie man mit einem neuen
von Russland installierten Marionetten
Regime ins Gespräch kommen könnte es
ging ihm also nicht darum festzustellen
wie man der Ukraine bei ihrer
Verteidigung helfen würde sondern nur
wie man sich weiter nicht mit Putin
unterhalten und wohl vor allem Geschäfte
machen können
nicht allein man kann wohl mit Fug und
Recht behaupten dass die Mehrheit der
deutschen französischen und
italienischen Politiker ganz ähnlich als
geopolitische Geisterfahrer unterwegs
waren all diese eines Licht der
Öffentlichkeit gekommenen Vorgänge legen
eine Maß an Inkompetenz und auch
moralischer Dekadenz offen das
eigentlich schon systemisch sein muss
ich muss gestehen dass mich selbst diese
grotesken viel Urteile der Politiker
Medien und Meinungsmacher mehr
schockiert haben als Putins überall
selbst und ich habe mich ernsthaft
gefragt in welcher Welt diese Menschen
eigentlich leben ich meine es kann doch
nicht die gleiche Welt wie die unsere
sein denn wir haben dieses Thema bereits
seit einigen Jahren genauestens
analysiert alles hier auf Youtube
veröffentlicht und gingen davon aus dass
Nachrichtendienste und Politik über die
gleichen Informationen verfügen
fakt ist natürlich Ende Februar Stunde
innerhalb weniger Stunden eine riesige
Zahl russischer Hubschrauber Panzer
Soldaten Raketen Schiffe und Jagdbomber
mit voller Geschwindigkeit von Norden
Süden und Osten über die Ukraine putin
hatte mit seiner Propaganda über Jahre
das Bild einer großen und modernen Armee
aufgebaut die viele Russen und Putin
Fans in aller Welt auf Augenhöhe mit der
nato-sahn die Ukraine hingegen hat
weniger Prozent auf so dass bei
oberflächlicher Betrachtung der Eindruck
entstehen konnte sie verfügen über eine
altmodische Armee aus das Corvette Ära
und ein paar westliche Waffen daher ist
es verständlich wenn jemand nicht auf
die Widerstandskraft des Landes wettete
allerdings nicht falls es sich um
Politiker handelt die eigentlich viel
besser informiert sein sollten
fakt ist allerdings auch seit
Kriegsausbruch haben sich die Dinge für
die Armee der Ukraine nochmals
dramatisch verändert und zwar so dass
ihr im Laufe des Sommers die Initiative
ergreifen konnte 6 Monate nach Beginn
der Invasion hingen die Russen bereits
in den Seilen diejenigen von euch die
uns schon lange Folgen
ärgern sich vielleicht an dieses Video
dass wir vor der Invasion veröffentlicht
haben darin haben wir euch erklärt wie
die Ukraine zu einer tödlichen Falle für
Russland werden könnte und genau das ist
geschehen
[Musik]
das Spektrum fataler Fehlkalkulation
Moskaus erstreckt sich hierbei vom
Widerstandswillen oder Widerstandskraft
der Ukraine über die Bereitschaft und
Einigkeit des Westens das angegriffene
Land zu unterstützen bis hin zu den
Fähigkeiten der eigenen russischen Armee
überhaupt in der Lage zu sein in den
ausgedehnten symmetrischen und
logistisch komplexen Krieg führen zu
können mittlerweile ist vollkommen klar
dass die streikkräfte der Ukraine nicht
nur wesentlich intelligenter agieren
können dass ich besser ausgebildet und
motiviert sind sondern dass sie den
Russen durch die Waffenhilfe des Westens
auch technologisch überlegen sind Putin
scheint sich darauf verlassen zu haben
dass seine fünften Kolonnen in der
europäischen Politik schon irgendwie
dafür sorgen würden dass keine
westlichen Waffen in die Ukraine strömen
würden und vor dem 24 Februar waren die
meisten vom Besten an die Ukraine
gelieferten Rüstungsgüter nicht einmal
hoch entwickelt oder tödlich und wenn
doch dann nur in kleinen Mengen trotzdem
haben die Waffen die die Alliierten den
Ukraine gegeben haben eine solche
Überlegenheit gegenüber der russischen
Ausrüstung gezeigt dass sie die
Kriegssituation völlig verändert haben
die technologische Überlegenheit ist
einfach enorm viel größer als man es
sich je hätte vorstellen in kommenden
Videos werden wir uns ansehen welche
überlegenen Taktiken die Ukraine
einsetzt warum die Unterschiede bei der
Kampfmoral und Intelligenz der
ukrainischen und russischen Truppen so
enorm sind und welche Auswirkungen dies
hat vergesst also bitte nicht das Abo
mit Glöckchen um sie nicht zu verpassen
in diesem Video konzentrieren wir uns
jedoch darauf wie genau der Faktoren
westliche Waffen es möglich gemacht hat
Vladimir Putins Neo internistische
Bestrebungen auszubremsen und
möglicherweise sogar zu zerschmettern
wir werden dies mit echten Beispielen
tun indem wir die Waffen als Referenz
nehmen die in diesem Krieg am
entscheidendsten sind wir werden euch
genau sagen welche Rolle und Funktion
jede von ihnen in jeder Phase dieses
Krieges gespielt hat also lasst uns ohne
große Umschweife zur Sache kommen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
Stahl Gewitter
wenn es eine Sache gibt in der Russland
nicht nur die Ukraine sondern praktische
jedes Land der Welt bei weitem
übertrifft dann ist es die Menge an
militärischen Bodengerät wir sprechen
von gepanzerten Fahrzeugen Panzern und
vor allem von Artillerie natürlich geht
es hier um die Quantität nicht zu sehr
um Qualität und Präzision aber das ist
eine andere Geschichte
und die Militärdoktrin bleibt mit
einigen Änderungen in wesentlichen die
das sowjetischen Ära sie setzen ihre
riesige Menge an Artillerie eine um eine
intensiven Bomben und raketenhagen zu
erzeugen das Gebiet säubern und den Weg
für Panzer und gepanzerte Fahrzeuge frei
machen sollte und nach dem Scheitern der
ersten Phase der Invasion war dies genau
die Strategie die Russland in der
don-bas-region verfolgt hat aber auch in
der Anfangsphase des Krieges war die
Stimmung in gewisser Weise nicht viel
anders allerdings mit einer sehr
wichtigen Nase der Kreml war in seiner
eigenen Propaganda Falle getappt von
seiner enormen Überlegenheit überzeugen
wollte dass die Operation blitzschnell
ablaufen zu diesen Zweck mobilisierten
sie eine riesige Menge an schwerem Gerät
um die ukrainische Armee buchstäblich zu
überrollen und ihre Ziele mit
Höchstgeschwindigkeit zu erreichen eben
im blitzkriegs Style in diesem Fall
wurde die Rolle der Artillerie durch
Präzisionsraketen ersetzt die von der
Luftwaffe und den Seestreitkräften
abgeschossen wurden das Problem der
Schwachpunkt dieser Form der
Kriegsführung ist dass durch die
Mobilisierung von so vielen
militärischen Gerät auch gigantische
Mengen an Nachschub benötigt werden
haben diese Tatsache immer wieder betont
und ich denke als treue visualpolitik
Zuschauer wisst ihr alle dass dies die
größte Schwäche der Russen war und immer
noch ist
dagegen hilft auch nicht die
Mobilmachung von Millionen Reservisten
ganz im Gegenteil wir können vermuten
dass die Russen die Logistik für einen
effektiven Plan B nicht richtig
organisiert haben der Transport von
Lastwagen braucht viel Zeit und die
Tyrannei der Entfernung wird zu einer
echten Herausforderung weil sie
versuchen eine große Truppe über
ziemlich schmale Straßen zu bewegen
Michael korfman Direktor für
russlandstudien bei der Forschungs- und
analyseorganisations CNA aber abgesehen
von der Frage des Nachschubs die in
diesem Krieg eine schüsselrolle gespielt
hat und weiterhin spielen wird liegt ein
weiteres großes Problem in den
russischen Waffen selbst in der
Strategie für ihren Einsatz und in ihren
tatsächlichen operativen
Kampffähigkeiten bevor wir uns also mit
der Rolle westlich Erwachen beschäftigen
müssen wir genau wissen wie ein
typisches russisches angriffspataillon
zusammengesetzt ist und wie es
organisiert ist
[Musik]
nun die ukrainischen Streitkräfte haben
festgestellt dass die Russen ihre
Artillerie auf Sicherheitsgründen in
eine Abstand von einem Drittel der
maximalen Reichweite von der Frontlinie
aufstellen
Linie besteht also aus Mörsern die
anderthalb Kilometer von den russischen
Truppen an der Front entfernt
aufgestellt sind dahinter in etwa 8 km
Entfernung sind die taktischen
ateliereinheiten mit kurzer und
mittlerer Reichweite platziert und in
einer weiteren etwas weiter entfernten
Linie zwischen 10 und 15 Kilometern ist
die tief Flieger Artillerie platziert
die den Feind von hinten angreifen
außerdem werde ich stärkste russische
Artillerie als area d9le Waffe
eingesetzt das heißt um den Feind am
überqueren zu hindern oder in notfalls
zum Rückzug aus einem bestimmten
Frontbereich zu zwingen
[Musik]
die Idee bei dieser Strategie ist ist
eine Art Stahlgewitter zu erzeugen
welches das Gebiet soll dort damit
später die Infanterie vorrücken kann um
mit Panzern und Schützenpanzern
Positionen einzunehmen auf diese Weise
sind die russischen Angriffe darauf
ausgelegt durch den Einsatz enormer
Feuerkraft solide Gewinne zu erzielen
das ist zum Beispiel der Grund warum so
viele Städte und Ortschaften den
Erdboden gleichgemacht werden
die Russen machen echt keine
Unterschiede es handelt sich um
hochgradig brutalen Ausdruck des
Angriffskrieges einer durch und durch
dummen Armee eine Armee die nur noch
über dumme Waffen und eine vollkommen um
nach der Führungsstruktur verfügt mit
anderen Worten der russischen Armee
bleibt nichts als ihre Artillerie um
voll einsatzfähig zu sein denn die wir
gesehen haben sind Luftangriffe keine
effektive Alternative zu diesem Plan und
genau aus diesem Grund sind die
Hauptakteure der Russen die mehrfach
raketenabschlusssysteme wie die Grad
unterstützt von der orangan und der
Tornado sie alle sind sowjetische
Technologie oder Adaption dieser
Technologie
[Musik]
Grad sind nicht präzise mehrfach
raketenabschlusssysteme die seit 1964
produziert werden und obwohl sie im
Laufe der Zeit upgradet wurden sind sie
im Grunde genommen immer noch eine
analoge und rudimentäre Waffe sie sind
in der Lage 40 hoch explosive 122 mm
Raketen in weniger als 20 Sekunden über
ein Gebiet von etwa 100 Metern Breite ab
zu feuern mit anderen Worten sie
ermöglichen einen wahren raketensturm
Raketen die wahllos alles zerstören
unabhängig davon ob es sich um
militärische oder zivile Ziele handelt
tatsache ist das ein typisches
russisches Bataillon mit dieser Waffe
mehr als 700 Raketen in weniger als
einer halben Minute abfeuern kann
tatsächlich hat Russland bis zum Beginn
des Sommers jeden Tag etwa 20.000
Artillerie Granaten abgefeuert
sagen wir einfach dass die Russen wissen
das ist sich um extrem ungenaue Waffen
handelt und versuchen die mangelnde
Genauigkeit mit einer riesigen Menge an
Feuerkraft auszugleichen allerdings wird
das Problem dass wir bereits gesehen
haben dadurch noch verschärft es werden
riesige und konstante Munitionsvorräte
benötigt um die russischen Linien
überhaupt aktiv zu halten ganz zu
schweigen davon dass dadurch blind links
geschossen wird ohne Rücksicht darauf ob
die Granaten am Ende in zivilgebieten
einschlagen mit anderen Worten es werden
Kriegsverbrechen begangen es wurden
Kriegsverbrechen in der Ukraine begangen
die Kommission beobachtete aus erster
Hand die Schäden die sprengstoffwaffen
an Wohngebäuden unter Infrastruktur
einschließlich Schulen und
Krankenhäusern angerichtet hatten kurz
gesagt damit der Russland nicht nur
vorrücken sondern das besetzte Gebiet
auch halten kann muss seine Nachhut sehr
gut geschützt sein denn dort befindet
sich die Munitionsdepots die seine
gesamte Strategie Speisen und wisst ihr
was genau an diesem Punkt kommen die
westlichen Waffen ins Spiel hört gut so
[Musik]
heiligen Speer zum Heiligen Heimat
erinnert ihr euch noch an folgendes
nehmen es ist der heilige jevalon ein
Bild das in der ersten Phase des Krieges
viral ging T-Shirts Flaggen und alle
Arten von Merchandising wurden mit
diesem Bild versehen und das ist kein
Wunder die mehr als 8.500 gelieferten
jewelen richteten in der ersten Phase
der Invasion verheerende Schäden an
russischen Panzern und gepanzerten
Fahrzeugen an natürlich war die Wahl
dieser Ausrüstung nicht zufällig
nachrichtendienstliche Informationen der
Krieg in Georgien und die
Zusammensetzung der russischen Armee
selbst machten sie zu einer Priorität
für die Alliierten die Idee war Waffen
an die Ukraine zu liefern die erstens
eine asymmetrische Kriegsführung gegen
die Invasion von gepanzerten Fahrzeugen
und Panzern ermöglichen würden zweitens
würden die Russen dadurch keine
Lufthoheit erringen können und drittens
wäre es so möglich ihn nachschubketten
der russischen Nachwuchs zu zerstören
und genau das waren die Aufgaben von
Panzerabwehrraketen tragbaren
Flugabwehrraketen und Drohnen
bedenkt bitte dass der schnelle
russische einmalige panzerten Einheiten
sowie nachschubfahrzeuge in
kilometerlangen Kolonnen ohne jeglichen
Schutz ausgesetzt hat und wisst ihr was
diese Strategie war ein voller Erfolg
und eine schreckliche Überraschung für
die Russen plötzlich verwandelten sich
ihre enorme militärische Überlegenheit
und ihre schnellen Angriffe in eine
Rennen mit endlosen Verlusten gepanzerte
Fahrzeuge und Hubschrauber wurden stark
aufgerieben werden gleichzeitig die
Nachschublinien verschwanden und die
gesamte Militäroperation ist
stockengericht
erschweren kann hinzu dass der Mangel an
Nachschub z.B an Treibstoff die
gepanzerten Einheiten noch stärker
gefährdete alles in allem ein Desaster
epischen Ausmaßes aber es sollte nur der
erste Streich sein
[Musik]
seitdem ist viel Zeit vergangen und da
die Ukraine ihrer frontkonsolidiert hat
und die Russen aufgeregt wurden hat sich
auch die Art der Kriegsführung geändert
das bedeutet auch dass ich die Art der
von den Verbündeten und insbesondere von
den Vereinigten Staaten gelieferten
Waffen geändert hat um euch einen
Eindruck zu verschaffen bis Ende August
haben allein die Amis rund 15,5
Milliarden Dollar an
sicherheitsunterstützung zur Verfügung
gestellt rechnet man die
Waffenlieferungen der anderen
Verbündeten Länder hinzu verdoppelt sich
diese Suche praktisch man könnte sagen
dass die Verbündeten insbesondere die
USA Großbritannien und Polen nach und
nach die Art der Waffen diese in die
Ukraine schickten abgegradet haben aber
auch Deutschland Frankreich Tschechien
die Slowakei und die Niederlande haben
entscheidende Beiträge geleistet wie wir
bereits erwähnt haben kehrten die Russen
nach dem ersten Desaster zur
sowjetischen militärdoch drin zurück und
die Ukraine hatte schlicht und
ergreifend keine Möglichkeit der
russischen Artillerie etwas
entgegenzusetzen das einzige was sie tun
konnten war zu versuchen Widerstand zu
leisten das erklärt warum der Monat Mai
für die Ukraine besonders hart war jeden
Tag kann man hunderte von Opfern hinzu
[Applaus]
[Musik]
und ja diese Opfer hätten wohl vermieden
werden können wenn der Westen schneller
für eine wirksame Verteidigung
notwendige Waffen geliefert und
ukrainische Soldaten daran ausgebildet
hätte erst ab Juni kamen diese neuen
Waffen zum Einsatz um dieser Situation
entgegen zu wirken im Gegensatz zu den
russischen Waffen die auf große
Feuerkraft ausgelegt sind werden
westliche Waffen mit einer besonderen
Prämisse entwickelt der Besessenheit von
Präzision das erfordert nicht nur eine
ausgefeilte Ausrüstung und Bewaffnung
sondern auch intelligente
aufklärungsfähigkeiten zurückgenommen
Zielbestimmung
im Fall der Ukraine wird die Aufklärung
auf drei verschiedene Arten erreicht zum
einen durch den intensiven Einsatz von
Drohnen die versuchen so nah wie möglich
an die russischen Linien heranzufliegen
viele von ihnen werden offensichtlich
abgeschossen und tatsächlich beträgt die
durchschnittliche Lebensdauer der von
der Ukraine eingesetzt wurde kommen 7
Tage aber sie erfüllen ihren Zweck eine
Materialschlacht eben in diesem Fall
sitzt die Ukraine jedoch am längeren
nachschubhebel während die Russen in
diesem Punkt durch die Technologie
Sanktionen hat getroffen recht schnell
Ausbluten der zweite Vorteil ist die
Zusammenarbeit mit der lokalen
Bevölkerung der Einsatz von
Spezialkräften logischerweise sind die
Ukraine hier stark im Vorteil
schließlich spielen sie auf heimischen
Boden und der dritte Vorteil sind die
Informationen die von ihren Verbündeten
bereitgestellt werden vergesst nicht
dass die Vereinigten Staaten die
Fähigkeit haben die russischen
Streitkräfte menoziös oder in Echtzeit
zu überwachen und zweifelt nicht daran
dass die Satelliten des Pentagons voll
auf die Situation in der Ukraine
gerichtet sind
auf diese Weise gelang es den Ukrainern
die Ziele so lokalisieren die
Koordinaten festzulegen und mit
präzisionsaktillerie anzugreifen die vor
allem ab Juni eintraf zu diesem
Zeitpunkt hat ein anderer der großen
Protagonisten dieses Krieges seinen
großen Auftritt sicherlich habt ihr alle
schon davon gehört die Hammers
[Musik]
das
Heim mobility artillery right System ist
ein hochpressives System das Artillerie
vorher mit einer Fehlerquote von weniger
als sieben Metern abfeuern kann mit
anderen Worten sie treffen praktisch
immer voll ins Schwarze das ist ein
enormer strategischer Vorteil vor allem
im Vergleich zu 100 m Genauigkeit der
Grad oder der sehr geringen Präzision
der modernsten russischen
langstreckenartellerie wie der Tornado
es außerdem haben die USA für den
Betrieb der 16 heimats die bis September
an die Ukraine geliefert wurden M30 und
M31 langstreckenmunition mit Reichweiten
zwischen 15 und 92 km geliefert diese
Raketen fliegen so schnell dass sie in
80 km entferntes Ziel in weniger als 2
Minuten erreichen können kurz gesagt
bedeutet das dass die Russen absolut
keine Zeit haben zu entkommen wenn sie
entdeckt werden
die Raketen verfügen außerdem über die
Fähigkeit ihre Flugbahn zu ändern so
dass es unmöglich ist festzustellen
woher sie abgeschossen wurden die Russen
können Ihnen also nicht nur nicht
entkommen sondern sich auch überhaupt
nicht gegen sie wären wer also über die
ins Bodenlose stützende Moral der Russen
lacht sollte sich wirklich die Frage
stellen ob er angesichts einer derartig
hoffnungslosen Unterlegenheit nicht auch
in Panik verfallen würde und nicht nur
das die Wahrheit ist dass die USA wenn
sie wollten der Ukraine immer noch einen
noch größeren Artillerie Vorteil
verschaffen könnten nicht nur durch die
Lieferung von mehr Heimat sondern auch
durch das Army tactical misses System es
handelt sich dabei um bodenbodenraketen
die die Ukraine seit langem fordert und
die eine Reichweite von Seiten 300 km
haben versteht ihr was es bedeutet in
300 km Entfernung mit absoluter
Präzision anzugreifen es ist verrückt
und versteht er jetzt wieso ist
vollkommen egal ist wie viele
Reservisten Putin mobilisiert er schickt
sie alle auf eine Schlachtbank
[Musik]
selbst wenn die russische Armee ihre
Logistik in den Griff bekäme was einen
echten Jahre langen Kulturwandel
voraussetzen würde hätte sie eine so
große Chance gegen die Waffen der
ukrainischen Streitkräfte wie
mittelalterliche Kavallerie gegen mg
Stellungen keine der ukrainische Feldzug
wird also weiter fortschreiten sowohl im
Süden als auch im Norden während ihre
Streitkräfte die russischen Verteidiger
in Südwesten festsetzen drücken die
Ukraine vom Norden hervor denn was wie
ein plötzlicher Durchbruch im Süden
aussieht ist in Wirklichkeit die
Fortsetzung einer langen Reihe
orchestrierter Aktion im Süden wie im
Nordosten der Ukraine der Schlüssel dazu
war die Zerstörung der ohnehin vor sind
wirklichen russischen Logistik mit Hilfe
der präzisionsaktillerie die
ukrainischen Angriffe eines Süden
begannen bereits vor Monaten sie dienten
nicht nur der Rückeroberung von
Territorium sondern waren auch Teil der
aufklärungsschlacht um Informationen zu
gewinnen und den russischen
Aufklärungseinheiten Informationen
vorzuenthalten diese frühen Aktionen
prägten das Schlachtfeld und zogen
schließlich russische Verstärkungen an
die militärplane in Kiew begannen dann
die Gelegenheit zu nutzen um akustische
Kräfte westlich des Jagdplatz zu
isolieren der Einsatz von Heimat war
hilfreich aber eine kluge Planung des
Einsatzes war entscheidend und wieder
einmal hat es sich gezeigt dass die
ukrainische Militärführung einfach viel
mehr Köpfchen besitzt als die russische
[Musik]
die ukrainische Strategen hielten stets
danach Ausschau wo die Russen ihre
Verteidigung ausdrücken würden um
Verstärkung gehen Süden zu schicken sie
wussten die Verteidigung ihrer Songs ist
für den Kreml eine politische Prestige
Frage gut natürlich geht es auch um die
Wasserversorgung der Creme welche die
Ukraine nach einem Fall ja sonst wieder
unter ihre Kontrolle bekäme die Ukraine
hatten zwar den Nordosten schon seit
einiger Zeit auf ihren Radar aber erst
als die Russen dort ihre Stellungen
auslösen mussten traf die Ukraine die
endgültige Entscheidung einen zweiten
Feldzug im Nordosten zu starten aber
auch als dieser zweite Feldzug in
Nordosten suchten die keine wieder nach
neuen Möglichkeiten und nach russischen
Schwachstellen und sie fanden eine
Gelegenheit im Norden von Herren im
Gegensatz zu den Russen hatten die
Ukraine also ein umfassendes
Operationskonzept das mögliche gegen
offensiven im Süden in Nordosten und
wahrscheinlich auch anderswo vorsah die
Durchführung dieser Operation in jedoch
nicht nur von der Zeit haben sondern
auch davon waren sich die Gelegenheit
dazu Boot die Russen hingegen haben
bisher jedoch immer wieder unter Beweis
gestellt dass sie auf
Opportunitätskosten Pfeifen sie schlagen
einfach los ohne Rücksicht auf eigene
Verluste das kann man vielleicht machen
wenn man eine unendlich größere Armee
mit überlegender Moral hat aber das
trifft im Falle Russlands eben nicht zu
[Musik]
außerdem verfügten die Ukraine eindeutig
über zweckgebundene und
situationsbedingte Reserven die sie für
geplante offensiven und für die Nutzung
von angriffsgelegenheiten vorgesehen
hatten die Schaffung dieser Reserven
erforderte eine gute Einschätzung von
risiko-täuschung operativer Sicherheit
und logistischer Bevorratung eine
weitere Schlüsselfaktor die Ukraine
haben eine überlegene
aufklärungsschlacht geführt die Russen
sind ganz einfach bei der taktischen
Aufklärung sehr schlecht und zwar schon
von Anfang an sonst hätten die auf gear
vorrückenden Panzertruppen wohl kaum
ihre Paradeuniformen eingepackt
taktische Aufklärung ist jedoch wichtig
um Überraschungen zu verhindern und
Schwachstellen des Gegners zu erkennen
und dann auszunutzen die
aufklärungsoperation die von Boden Luft
und elektronischen Aufklärungseinheiten
durchgeführt werden zeichnen ein Bild
des Geländes der feindlichen
Dispositionen der Reserven der
wichtigsten Transportwege und vor allem
der Logistik natürlich wird die
taktische Aufklärung der Ukraine wie
gesagt durch strategische Aufklärung aus
anderen Quellen ergänzt die Amis und
Briten lassen verantwortlich nicht
lumpen und so verfügt die Ukraine nach
fast acht Monaten intensiver
Kriegsführung und den 8 Jahren seit der
ersten Invasion über viele hochrangige
Kommandeure die erfahrene Strategen sind
und auch über hochkarätige operative
Erfahrungen verfügen vielleicht
mittlerweile sogar über bessere als ihre
nato-pendance
kennen ihren Feind sehr gut und wissen
wie sie strategische Risiken und Chancen
abwägen können diese Befehlshaber ihrer
Stäbe und auch die Unteroffiziere sind
außerordentlich geschickter an ihre
Truppen bei der Planung und Durchführung
groß angelegter militärische Operationen
zu führen für russland hingegen hat
schon traditionell ein gewaltiges
Defizit an qualifizierten
Unteroffizieren wir haben dieses Thema
ausführlich in unserem Video über die
Schwächen der russischen Armee behandeln
alles was dort gesagt wurde gilt nach
wie vor bzw mehr denn je denn mit der
mobilenmachung dass sich der Mangel an
kompetenten Unteroffizieren noch
vergrößern die eingezogenen Männer
werden kopflos und ohne ordentliche
Führung in die Schlacht geworfen
eigentlich begeht hier Putin
vorsätzlichen Mord an seiner eigenen
Armee aber die Erfahrung der
ukrainischen Unteroffiziere gründet sich
auch in der Asymmetrie der Befehls
Philosophie
Russland steuert die Operation zentral
manche munkeln sogar das Putin selbst
die Einheiten kommandiert währenddessen
gewährt die missionsführung der Ukraine
ihren Offizieren wesentlich mehr
Freiheiten bei der Nutzung von Chancen
so haben die Führer im Feld viel bessere
Gelegenheiten dazu zu lernen was auch
ihre Moral steigert so wie die der von
ihnen geführten Truppen bei schnell
voranschreitenden Operationen wie in
Person kann nur derjenige der sich nicht
ständig an einen übergeordnetes
Hauptquartier wenden muss das operative
Tempo bestimmen dominieren und
letztendlich die Initiative ergreifen
das Zusammenspiel dieser fünf Faktoren
sowie der Mut der ukrainischen Soldaten
im Nahkampf und die Ziellosigkeit der
russischen Soldaten war ausschlaggebend
für den Erfolg der Ukraine bei der
Rückeroberung großer Teile ihres
Territoriums und die russische Armee
scheint keine Antwort auf das zu haben
was die ukrainischen Streitkräfte mit
ihr machen wir erleben kaskadenartige
Fehlschläge die wahrscheinlich noch eine
ganze Weile andauern werden die frisch
mobil eine russischen Truppen werden für
die Streitkräfte der Ukraine
wahrscheinlich nicht mehr darstellen als
mitschields Schilde aus Fleisch so
zynisch dies auch klingenmark es ist
leider die bittere Realität für
Hunderttausende russischer Männer
seit wann beginnt der Operation war
Barossa im Zweiten Weltkrieg hat die
russische Armee keine so schreckliche
Serie von Rückschlägen auf den
Schlachtfeld erleben müssen und da viele
Truppen westlich des nährt bei
festsetzen könnten die kommenden Tage
noch viel schlimmer für sie werden da
kann das russische Staatsfernsehen noch
so behaupten es würde nur zwei Monate
dauern bis die kürzlich mobilisierten
Soldaten an die Front der Ukraine kämen
aber machen wir doch mal den
Reality-Check kann man komplexe
kombinierte Kriegsführung insbesondere
für große Verbände in zwei Monaten
trainieren beherrschen neue Feldwebel
nach zwei Monaten Training die
Grundsätze effektiver Führung aus dem FF
kann man ein System der militärlogistik
das vollkommen veraltet und seit
Jahrzehnten von korruptionsadressen ist
in zwei Monaten wieder auf Vordermann
bringen und sogar hochskalieren damit es
eine viel größere Truppenzahl versorgen
kann kann man binnen zwei Monaten die
zerstörte Moral der Soldaten
wiederherstellen und ihr massives
Misstrauen gegenüber der eigenen Führung
beseitigen ich denke uns allen ist klar
dass die Antwort auf all diese Fragen
nein lautet
da bringt es auch nichts das noch so
viele Propagandisten und pseudo-experten
im russischen Staatsfernsehen behaupten
die Dinge würden für Russland besser
werden wenn nur der Winter einbreche als
ob der Winter einen Wunderwaffe ist
Kreml wäre nun ja ein zwei Monaten kann
sich das Wetter ändern aber nicht die
ganze Kultur eines verrotteten Militärs
das dauert Jahre oder sogar Jahrzehnte
fakt ist nämlich dass die meisten der
einberuflichen Reservisten noch nicht
einmal ordentlich ausgebildet wurden ja
sie dienten ihre Zeit in der Armee ab
weil sie mussten mehr aber auch nicht es
handelt sich meist also gar nicht um
Reservisten wie man sie in NATO Ländern
kennt der diese trainieren mit ihren
Einheiten verfügen über entsprechende
Fähigkeiten die Unteroffiziere über
autonome Führungserfahrung russische
Soldaten wissen hingegen vor allem eines
dass ihre Offiziere und Unteroffiziere
korrupt und sie selbst ihnen vollkommen
schnuppe sind die meisten sind einfach
nur durch Angst motiviert das ist die
schlimmste Form von Moral Angst ist zwar
bei allen neuen Soldaten normal aber das
Vertrauen in die Führung die Kameraden
und die Ausrüstung und die Sache selbst
mindert die Angst
die russische Armee setzt deswegen
massiv blockierende Einheiten ein das
sind Einheiten die Desertion verhindern
und der sateure erschießen damit wird
das Konzept tötet den Feind oder Wärme
getötet auf eine andere Ebene gehoben
töte den Feind oder werde von ihm oder
von uns getötet aus all diesen Gründen
ist also ersichtlich dass die
Mobilisierung von 300.000 oder mehr
Männern in einer Katastrophe für
Russland enden wird und wahrscheinlich
wird die Ukraine hierzu nicht mal mehr
heimatsysteme brauchen deswegen zögert
Washington im Moment der Ukraine alles
zu geben was Sie sich erträumt in sich
fürchten nach der Lieferung die
Kontrolle über einen Großteil der Waffen
zu verlieren außerdem gehört es wohl
auch zur Taktik des Pentagon in diesem
Krieg die russischen Kräfte nach und
nach aus der Reserve zu locken und sie
so wirklich gründlich durch die Ukraine
aufreiben zu lassen daher war es wichtig
Ihnen stets noch einen gewissen Hauch
jener trügerischen Hoffnung zu geben
irgendeinen Blumentopf in der Ukraine
gewinnen zu können
aber wie dem auch sei tatsache ist dass
die Ukraine auch ohne Raketen mit 300
Kilometern Reichweite nur mit den
bereits in Einsatz befindlichen Raketen
fast jedes Ziel in der russischen
militärischen Hinterhand mehr teuflische
Genauigkeit treffen können
Kommandozentrale Treibstoff
Kommunikationseinrichtungen und sogar
die russische Artillerie selbst auf
diese Weise fügen die Ukraine den
russischen Truppen massiven Schaden zu
und angesichts der größeren Reichweite
der heimats können sich die Russen eben
nicht verteidigen bisher haben sie dies
mit touchka urraketen versucht Raketen
die zwar eine größere Reichweite haben
aber trotzdem leicht abzufangen und sehr
langsam zu bedienen sind die Ergebnisse
waren daher eher enttäuschend hinzu
kommt dass die amerikanischen Raketen
wie gesagt ihre Flugbahn ändern können
und auch die heimatserver ziemlich
schnell und wendig sind so ihren
Standort wechseln können selbst wenn es
den Russen also irgendwie gelingen
sollte ihre Position festzustellen sind
sie bereits verschwunden bevor ein
Gegenangriff erfolgen kann
[Musik]
deshalb versuchen die Russen in der
Praxis nur elektronische
kriegsführungssysteme und gps-störsender
einzusetzen mit diesem System versuchen
Sie die heimatlenkraketen zu verwirren
das Problem dabei nun der Einsatz dieser
Ausrüstung erfordert eine riesige Menge
an Treibstoff und erinnert ihr euch noch
daran was die Ukraine mit russischen
Treibstoff und nachschublagern machen
ja das Ergebnis ist also dass die Russen
die elektronischen Kampfsysteme mit
denen sie immer so sehr gepost haben nur
sporadisch einsetzen können und die
Frage die sich sicher viele von euch
jetzt stellen ist wie sehen die
Auswirkungen des Einsatzes der US
Hightech Artillerie im Detail aus nun
wegen der großen Reichweite und der
hohen dressicherheit musste Russland
zusätzlich zu den erlittenen Schäden
seine Munitionsdepots und andere Vorräte
von der freundlichen Weg verlegen das
erschwert natürlich alle Operationen
erheblich erst recht für eine Armee in
der man noch nie was von Paletten und
Gabelstapler angehört hat die Ukraine
behauptet sie können den meisten
russischen Nachschublinien im Süden
treffen alles in allem sind die
russischen Truppen also nach dem Einsatz
der Heimat viel schlechter versorgt
haben erhebliche Schäden erlitten und
mussten außerdem besetzte Gebiete
aufgeben die sie einfach nicht mehr
halten konnten
ganze Frontabschnitte der Russen sowohl
im Nordosten also Süden sind
infolgedessen also zusammengebrochen und
nicht nur das es ist auch der Grund für
Nachrichten wie diese
Russen bei gegen Angriff 8 zu 1 in der
Unterzahl und das alles danke für 16
heimersystemen ja genau bisher haben die
USA von dem ersten 400 in ihrem Arsenal
befindlichen nur 16 Stück an die Ukraine
geliefert und vier weitere sind gerade
in das neueste Hilfspaket aufgenommen
worden stellt euch aber vor was
passieren würde wenn Washington
beschließt diese Zahl zu verdoppeln oder
was von der russischen Armee übrig
bliebe wenn Sie mit allen 400 Systemen
konfrontiert wäre tatsache ist dass
diese Waffe so erfolgreich ist dass sie
in den kommenden Jahren eine
Schlüsselrolle bei der Verteidigung
nicht nur Osteuropa sondern auch andere
Länder auf der ganzen Welt spielen wird
[Musik]
nun wieder euch gesagt haben war diese
Waffe ein Wendepunkt für die ukrainische
Armee aber sie war nicht die einzige wir
dürfen nicht vergessen wie wichtig die
Rolle der jewelen in der ersten Phase
des Krieges war wir bauen die
Fähigkeiten unserer Raketen und
artilleriekräfte aus ich habe eine
Absichtserklärung über den Erwerb von
etwa 500 m142 heimats 80 Batterien des
homersystems unterzeichnet Marius
blaschak Verteidigungsminister Polens
heimeres Raketen haben in der Ukraine
das Blatt gewendet und die US-Armee
sucht jetzt nach Möglichkeiten bis zu
500 weiter zu bauen neben der Ukraine
ist da vielleicht bedeutendste Käufer
Taiwan das jetzt ein 29 heimers
bestellen will oder die
Flugabwehrsysteme wie die S300 die von
Verbündeten aus den ehemaligen
kommunistischen Block gespendet wurden
oder die Rolle die die ns-cence spielen
werden von denen die USA einfach 8
Einheit zugesagt haben und die bald
geliefert werden sollen Systeme die die
Russen daran hindern den ukrainischen
Luftraum zu kontrollieren was sie nach 7
Monaten Krieg immer noch nicht geschafft
haben und wartet einen Moment denn wir
müssen Euch noch unbedingt die A M88
hoch
geschwindigkeitsabwehrraketen vorstellen
[Musik]
diese hochmodernen Raketen ermöglichen
es den Ukrainern das gegnerische Rad da
vorübergehend auszuschalten um sicher
angreifen zu können das ist eine der
Gründe warum wir wieder zahlreiche
Einsätze der ukrainischen Luftwaffe
sehen um dieser Raketen einsetzen zu
können mussten die ukrainischen zu hohe
27 und Nick 29 aus das tobizheit
übrigens mehr als 2 Monate lang
umgerüstet werden und das mitten im
Krieg ein weiterer Bereich der
Überlegenheit der ukrainischen
Streitkräfte gegenüber den russischen in
puncto Agilität und Lernfähigkeit und
wir dürfen auch nicht die 126
amerikanischen m77 hauptbitzen vergessen
die bis Anfang September in die Ukraine
geschickt worden diese Haubitzen sind
Kurzstrecken Artillerie für die
ukrainischen fronteinheiten die die
russischen Frontlinien in einer
Genauigkeit von nur 5 Metern treffen
können also ein echter Albtraum für die
Russen kurz gesagt wir könnten Euch ewig
über die enorme kolossale und
gigantische Bedeutung jeder einzelne der
westlichen Waffen der Ukraine gespendet
wurden erzählen insbesondere der
amerikanischen in diesem Video haben wir
versucht uns auf die wichtigsten zu
konzentrieren damit ihr jedes Muster
erkennt dass ich hinter dem Chaos mit
dem die Russen konfrontiert sind
verbirgt ein strategischer Plan der von
außen betrachtet manchmal nur wie ein
einfaches Zahlenwerk aussieht aber jetzt
seid ihr an der Reihe meint ihr der
besten und insbesondere die Europäische
Union sollten sich stärker darüber
Bemühen der Ukraine moderne Waffen zu
geben könnte es sein dass die Ukraine
mittlerweile über die stärkste Armee
Europas verfügt eine Armee welche die
einzige glorreiche russische nicht nur
ab Wert und in den Schatten stellt
sondern auch vernichtet wie immer sind
wir auf eure angerichtete Diskussion zu
diesem Thema schon mächtig gespannt ich
hoffe dass euch dieses Video gefallen
hat wenn ihr vielleicht auch etwas dabei
gelernt habt falls ja gib uns bitte ein
Like testen und Freunden und
vergessliches Abo mit Glöckchen und
keines unserer Videos mehr zu verpassen
natürlich freuen uns auch jederzeit über
eine Spende von euch mit der uns hält
dieses Projekt weiterzuführen in PayPal
Link dazu findet ihr in der Beschreibung
unter dem Video mach's gut und bis bald